Transcriber: Rama Ali
المدقّق: Arwa Mohamed
ماذا ؟ ألم تبدأي بنظام غذائي
(ريجيم) ؟
ماذا؟
أحسنتِ سمعت أنك قمت بتمارين رياضة اليوم.
متى تنوين البدء باتباع نظام غذائي؟
من المؤسف أن هكذا وجه ، له جسم كهذا.
كل ما في الأمر،
أنه يتطلب القليل من الإرادة.
نحن نتكلم هكذا لأجلك ،
أنت بهذا الشكل تؤذين نفسك
إن بقيت هكذا لن ينظر أحد إليك.
ابنتي ، هذا يطعم القرية بأكملها،
هل ستأكلين كل هذا بمفردك؟!
هذا جزء من التعليقات التي كانت هي تسمعها.
سأعرفكم بها ، قبل أن أعرفكم بنفسي،
اسمها سارة خوري،
عمرها ثلاثين سنة.
و قد أمضت سبعة وعشرين سنة من عمرها،
تحاول فقدان الوزن
لأن الوزن أصبح يؤثر على صحتها
بعد أن أثر في نظرتها لنفسها،
و على عملها ، وعلى كل شيء آخر في حياتها.
و سأعرفكم بنفسي ،
اسمي سارة خوري
عمري ثلاثة وثلاثون سنة ،
وقد فقدت  من الوزن ثلاثة وثلاثين كيلو غرام
يعني ..
(تصفيق)
يعني أني فقدت كيلوغرام واحد
من الوزن عن كل سنة.
سوف أشرح لكم كيف ،
انتظروا ثانية.
منذ أن كنت صغيرة ،
و أنا أحاول أن أكون جميلة.
كنت أسمع عبارات مثل: أنتِ مهذبة جداً،
أو أنتِ ذكيّة، أو أنتِ شاطرة.
لكن لم أسمع أبداً كلمة : أنتِ جميلة.
كانوا يلقبون أختي بجميلتنا، وكانوا
يقولون لها أنتِ جميلةٌ جداً، ويحبونها.
أمّا أنا فكانوا ينادوني حسن الصبي،
فظننت أنه يجب أن أكون جميلة لكي يحبونني .
كبرت قليلاً و صرت أسمع كلاماً مثل:
أنتِ ممتلئة
و مكتنزة ، و صرت أقارن نفسي بالفتيات
الأخريات، اللواتي كنّ معي في المدرسة
اللواتي كنّ يلبسن التنورة
لكن أنا كنت ألبس البنطال.
لأن جسمي لم يكن جميلاً كفاية،
وأنا لم أكن جميلة كفاية مثلهنّ.
في مراهقتي، بدأت أسمع عبارات مثل :
أنتِ جميلة، ولكن..
أنتِ جميلة، لكن بدينة.
أنتِ جميلة فقط وأنتِ جالسة،
لكن إذا وقفتِ يغير المرء رأيه
أنتِ جميلة، لكن ليس لديكِ أنوثة
لأنك بدينة.
و دائماً كنت أرى،
كنت دائماً أرى الفتيان  يتغزلون بصديقاتي
تمنّيت لو أن أحدهم تغزّل بي ذات مرة.
ذات مرة اقترب شاب مني ، كنت مع أصدقائي
قلت لنفسي ، حان الوقت
لا بد أنه سيتغزل بي الآن
فكرت بأنني أريد أن أتكبّر على الشاب،
اقترب مني وقال لي، عفواً
هل من الممكن أن تخبريني بإسم صديقتك،
لأنها لا ترد عليّ.
و بالطبع لم أحضر حفل تخرّجي،
لأنني لم أكن جميلة كفاية.
و بدأ عملي يتأثر،
أصبحت غير قادرة على إعطاء رأيي.
لم أستطع أن أعمل ، لم أستطع أن أخرج
كنت منزويةً طوال الوقت
و المسلسل الوحيد الذي مثّلت فيه.
أعطوني دور إمرأة حامل بتوأم،
نعم، مسلسل “قلبي دق“.
سمعت “قلبي دق“.
أعطوني دور إمرأة حامل بتوأم،
و كنت دائماً أسمع عبارة:
لا حاجة لأن نضع لها شيء لتبدو حامل.
فهي تبدو حامل بما فيه الكفاية ،
وبشعة بما فيه الكفاية.
عشت ثلاثين سنة مع هذه الأفكار،
أبحث عن إجابة، أبحث عن طريقة ،
كي أكون جميلة لأكون محبوبة.
أنضممت إلى مجموعة روحية.
بدأت أشر فيها بالحب،
بدأت أشعر بحب الأشخاص
بحب أكبر، لكنني لم أكن أصدق
لأنه كان هناك دائماً صوت داخل رأسي،
أصبح أعمق من وعيي
يخبرني ، أنه ليس من الممكن أن يحبني أحد،
لأنني لست جميلة ولست نحيفة.
نسيت قصة حياتي .
(تصفيق)
بدأت بمسيرتي بعلم النفس
وبدأت بالتنقل من كتاب إلى كتاب.
حتى وجدت الجواب،
عرفت أن هناك شخص واحد
يجب أن يحبني قبل أن يحبني أي شخص آخر
هذا الشخص هو أنا.
بدأت أحب كل جزء مني ،
بدأت أحب كل عمر مني .
تكلمت مع سارة الصغيرة
سارة التي كانت تأكل لتحمي نفسها.
التي كانت تأكل لأنها خائفة من الضّرب.
تكلمت مع سارة الأكبر قليلا ، التي تأكل
لتبحث عن حبّ أمّها،
وهي ترى أمها تبتعد عنها شيئًا فشيئًا
و أمها أيضًا، من المؤكد أنها
كانت تبحث عن أحد يحبّها.
تكلمت مع سارة المراهقة،
التي تبلغ ستة عشر سنة .
والتي بدأت تختبر ما يسمى نوبات هلع.
لا أعرف إذا ما اختبر أحد منكم هذا الشيء
من قبل، لكنه شيء بشع للغاية.
دقات قلب سريعة ، تشعرون وكأنكم
تغيبون عن الوعي أو تموتون.
وأنا، في هذه اللحظة، في أول مرة اختبرت
فيها نوبات الهلع، شعرت أنها النهاية.
شعرت أن هذه اللحظة التي سأموت فيها،
ولم أكن أستطيع مشاركة أحد بذلك.
تكلمت مع سارة التي تبلغ أربعة وعشرين سنة،
التي خسرت أمّها بمرض،
كان يسبب لها خسارة مستمرة بالوزن، إلى أن
توفّيت وهي بوزن ستة وثلاثين كيلوغرامًا.
تكلمت مع سارة التي كانت بهذا الوزن،
ولم تكن تستطيع أن تتحرك
و من بعد علاج روحي و نفسي ،
ومن بعد مجهود كبير
ومن بعد حب كبير، أصبحت سارة هكذا.
الفيديو غير مسرّع ،
(تصفيق).
تكلمت مع كلك هؤلاء ، تكلمت مع كل جزة منّي.
و قلت لها ، لم تعودي بحاجة لأن تأكلي، لم
تعودي بحاجة لتحمي نفسك، لأنني الآن أحميكِ
أنت بأمان الآن.
تكلّمت مع سارة التي تنتظر الحب.
قل لها، لم يعد هناك داعٍ لتأكلي كي تملئي
هذا الفراغ، أنا أحبّكِ و سأمنحك هذا الحب.
و إذا كنتم تنتظرون  النظام الغذائي
الذي اتبعته، أنا لم اتبع نظامًا غذائيّا.
أعتذر.
أو، أستطيع القول أن هذا هو النظام الغذائي
الذي اتبعته، نظام الرسائل،
يجب أن تجربوه، لمن يرغب
و سارة التي ترونها بهذا الوزن
تكلمت معها، وهي تمثل
قلت لها شكرًا
شكرًا لأنك مثلتي رغم كل شيء،
لأنك حققتي لي حلمي رغم كل المصاعب.
سارة التي هي بهذا الوزن، بعثت لها رسالة
من جملة واحدة
قلت لها، أنتِ قويّة جداً، لأنكِ تخطيت
كل ذلك، وبقيتي صامدة.
و بقيتي مستمرة، والآن من المؤكد أنك
تستحقين أن تعيشي بفرح.
و من المؤكد أنك تستحقين
أن تخرجي من هذا الخوف،
و من المؤكد، أنك جميلة كفاية.
شكرًا.
(تصفيق).